Speaker 1: Well, the last 24 hours have
been some of the most consequential that we
have had in months. We first heard from the
current attorney general, Merrick Garland,
that no one is above the law, that he is open to
prosecuting former President Donald Trump. But
then in addition to that, we learned, based on a
very interesting report from The Washington Post
that Donald Trump is currently under criminal
investigation by the Justice Department.
This was the question, is the Justice Department
criminally investigating Donald Trump? Have they
paid attention to the January six committee or to
what's going on in Georgia or to whatever else,
and done their own investigation and determined
this is worthy, not necessarily of charges,
but of criminal investigation. And the news
that broke over the last 24 hours is that the
answer is yes. We're going to look at both of
these things. I was going to lead with Garland,
but Garland being open to prosecuting Trump is
irrelevant if there's no probe. It now has been
revealed that there is indeed a probe. Washington
Post Report. Justice Department investigating
Trump's actions in January six criminal probe.
People familiar with the probe said. Investigators
are examining the former president's conversations
and have seized the phone records of top aides.
Understand this is already historic. It is not
typical that a president leaves office and then
is under federal criminal investigation. Now it
may go to absolute nothing. This investigation
may end up in the toilet, flushed 10 to 15 times.
But this is already an unprecedented and unique
situation. The Justice Department is investigating
Trump's actions as part of its criminal probe
of efforts to overturn the 2020 election,
according to four people familiar with the matter,
prosecutors who are questioning witnesses before
a grand jury, including two top aides to Vice
President Pence, have asked in recent days
about conversations with Trump, his lawyers
and others in his inner circle who sought to
substitute Trump allies for certified electors
from some states. Joe Biden won. This is the
fake electoral scam. The prosecutors have asked
hours of detailed questions about meetings
Trump led in December of 2020 and January 2021.
His pressure campaign on Pence to overturn the
election and what instructions Trump gave his
lawyers and advisers about fake electors and
sending electors back to the states. The people
said some of the questions focused directly on
Trump's on the extent of Trump's involvement
in the fake elector effort led by his outside
lawyers, including John Eastman and Rudy Giuliani.
This is major focus, and it appears that a lot
of the focus is on the fake elector scheme.
The belief among some legal experts is that that's
probably the easiest one to prove, but it is all
very much related generally to Trump's attempt to
overthrow the government and to install himself.
The guy who did not win the illegitimate wouldn't
even be to say an illegitimate president. He just
wouldn't. He wasn't the president. He
didn't win. The article goes on to say
Justice Department investigators in April received
phone records of key officials and aides in the
Trump administration, including Mark Meadows, his
chief of staff. That effort is another indicator
of how expansive the January six probe had become
well before the hearings in June and July. This
is another really important question or answer.
I guess we would better say. We were wondering
not only is was there a probe, but did the probe
only start because of the January six committee
hearings? And it appears that the answer is no.
There was actually a criminal probe of Trump
that started well before that. What do we know
about some of the build up to all of this? Well,
Jacqueline Alemany, who works for The Washington
Post and was part of breaking this story, appeared
on MSNBC and talked about it. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: That's exactly right, Willie. We've
reported that prosecutors who have recently
brought in people like Greg Jacobs and Marc Short
and potentially more, we just you know, people
were brought up we might not be aware of just yet.
But people who were very close to Mike Pence
had firsthand accounts and were witness to
the pressure campaign being applied on him
to overturn the results of the election.
Indeed, we're also in the room for other meetings
involving some of the constitutional schemes
being put forth by Trump allies, people
like John Eastman. Before the president,
they were asked about those interactions. They
were asked about meetings in December of 2021
and January of 2020 and December of 2020 and
January of 2021. We also know that they were
asked specifically about the pressure being
put on Mike Pence, according to sources.
And we also know that these phone records that
have been newly reported and obtained by the
Justice Department included phone records from
Trump, top Trump aides and Mark Meadows as well.
Someone else who was also in the room for a
lot of these really explosive and meetings
that have recently garnered a lot of scrutiny.
Speaker 1: All right. So the point here that I
can only make a limited number of times in in
our program, but I think needs to be made, as
we all have been to some degree, desensitized
by these last many years. And I include myself
in that. But this is not normal. This is
extraordinary. These are extraordinary times
that we are living in. The former president is
under criminal investigation by the following
administrations. Justice Department. Now, what
could be the possible crimes? I've been reading
up on this this morning as a non-lawyer who spoke
to some lawyers. There are three possibilities.
The easiest to prove would likely be conspiracy
to defraud the United States. This would be over
the fake electors. Sending fake electors would be
committing a fraud, as Trump says, on the on the
United States. Other possible crimes. Obstruction
of an official proceeding. Now, there are lots of
variations of this, but the one being looked
at by the January 6th committee seems to be
1512 C, which theoretically carries up to 20
years in prison. I don't expect that that's
ever going to be Trump's future, partially
because he won't live 20 years. And then also
seditious conspiracy is possible. But again,
when we anything with the word sedition in it,
the bar to prove criminal intent is a difficult
one to overcome. And it's sort of related to why
I know I've said this before, you don't often
see perjury charges, even though people do lie
in court all the time. And we will just have to
follow it and see. Now, if you weren't sure about
the consequential nature of the midterm election
in 2022 and of course, the presidential in 2024,
if you did think that those elections were
important before, they are absolutely above
and beyond important now. Trump got away to
different impeachments without conviction because
Republicans had the Senate. You have to understand
that if control goes back to Republicans in 2022,
a lot of this stuff is completely dead in the
water now. Might charges be brought against
Trump before that? Maybe. I don't think so. I
don't know. But I would expect Donald Trump to
announce his candidacy very soon. He believes
that that would be a way to shield himself
from the criminal probe. Now, if you want me
to be honest, if I look at my crystal ball,
I expect that even if there is such an
investigation, at some point we will
hear there is really no precedent for charging a
former president of the United States. I know I'm
being pessimistic, but that's my crystal ball.
But the next question becomes, would it Trump
announcing his candidacy do anything to shield him
here? And Merrick Garland says the answer is no